i'm so used to thinking about science
i'm not sure how to make myself stop
as soon as i think about not thinking
about it i'm thinking about it
well why don't you just think about
something else like what
i don't know read a comic book how do
you think the spider that bit peter
parker got radioactive
science how do you think bruce banner
got exposed to gamma rays
science all right when the green goblin
flies is that all right
science i know you don't want to hear
this but i find prayer can bring
incredible peace of mind come on mary
i'm trying to help the kid
you just need a new hobby very well what
are yours
smoking drinking and gambling but we can
find you something almost as fun
come on sheldon let's get that blood
pumping
i'd rather not do it
little exercise help get your head out
of your butt
[Applause]
what do you think i think i hate this
well you're not thinking about science
now am i right
i'm thinking about how miserable i am
[Music]
b14 b14
what else you got
are you positive other people's fingers
haven't been in this
i made sure to get you a new one it
doesn't look neat it's new
let it rip
i'm still thinking about science it's
okay
just aim for the front pin
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
you